I am NOT happy to have to tell you this
today but I have to tell you this today
because it's the undeniable reality
Donald Trump is very quickly retreating
from his claims of just a total earth
shattering victory of heroic nature with
the Singapore summit involving North
Korean leader Kim jong-un just last week
Donald Trump was claiming that we were
already seeing very fast
denuclearization taking place by North
Korea now Trump is backing off he's
using the word possible to describe the
North Korea deal and he's talking about
how it may not quote work out at all how
quickly things change in just days we
were told that this was the deal to end
all deals Trump told us Kim jong-un is
not only trustworthy but he's smart and
he's funny and he's a great negotiator
and he's just an all-around really fun
person Trump led us to believe we were
told the deal was already becoming a
reality and none of it is true and we
learned last week that North Korea is
allegedly expanding a nuclear research
site and now Donald Trump has completely
changed his language altogether he was
interviewed over the holiday weekend on
Fox News Sunday and just listen to the
language he's using very different
language from what we heard in the 48
hours following the summit take a look
deal with him
president Trump told Fox News Sunday he
trusted Kim jong-un would dismantle his
nuclear program but admitted the deal
they agreed to in Singapore last month
could fall apart have I been in deals
have you been in things where people
didn't work out it's possible that's far
from the president's confident tone
arriving home from the summit there is
no longer a nuclear threat but new
satellite imagery shows expansion of a
missile manufacturing site capable of
producing missiles that could hit US
military installations in Asia so as a
reminder the language when Trump landed
from the summit was drastically
different they put up part of that tweet
let's actually look at that tweet Trump
said quote just landed a long trip but
everybody can now feel much safer than
the day I took office Yeah right there
is no longer a new
threat from North Korea meeting with Kim
jong-un was an interesting and very
positive experience
north Korea has great potential in the
future Donald Trump is also completely
changing his explanation of what he
promised Kim jong-un remember that at
the summit Trump agreed to end a whole
bunch of joint military exercises with
South Korea Trump now is claiming during
that same Fox News interview I believe
it was with Maria Bartiromo total
softball interview I mean really
embarrassing for Maria saying quote we
gave nothing I went there so the papers
say he went so we had a meeting we
didn't do anything
Trump in his own words about the
previously heroic meeting is saying so
we had a meeting we didn't do anything
and this is the preparing himself to be
able to say if and when it doesn't work
out listen we didn't give them anything
all we did was have a meeting that's all
and it's actually even worse because the
one thing that North Korea did agree to
do that was sort of notable remember
most of what North Korea agreed to was
the same stuff that they had agreed to
many times before and never followed
through on the one unique element of the
agreement that North Korea agreed to in
principle was to repatriate the remains
of American troops that were killed
during the Korean War Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo makes you throw up a little
bit in your mouth when you even say that
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said a
few days ago that it hasn't happened he
was asked during a hearing with the
Senate Appropriations Committee whether
the repatriation of the remains is
happening and he said we have not yet
physically received them and when he was
asked so to speak whether they were in
the mail refused to say anything else
I don't want to be crass but do we even
really believe that North Korea has the
remains of soldiers from 65 years ago
I'm not saying it's impossible like of
course they might but do we even believe
that they have these remains I genuinely
have no idea and even so it's not the
best trade off right we get those
remains back in an exchange we get to
you know remove those the military
exercises you were doing with the South
Koreans or eliminate sanctions it's not
a very good exchange for the United
States
security guarantees which of course we
as usual the term is thrown around we
don't actually know what are those
guarantees mean we still haven't even
heard that in any case absolute and
utter diplomatic joke remember that
trump said all along the press and the
fake news and democrats whoever they're
trying to undermine the historic deal
now Trump is saying we did nothing we
have we had a meeting and we have a
possible deal and deals don't always
work out and the scariest thing about
all of this is that Trump did the summit
he bragged about it he called it
this massive geopolitical victory his
claims were widely reported and later
Trump will claim not but we never
claimed unilateral victory it was no big
deal
even if I called it a victory because it
doesn't always work out and these are
just possible deals and we didn't commit
anything to begin with and his followers
will go with it hook line and sinker
yeah I feel like this whole thing has
just been reduced to a photo opportunity
yeah but some would say it was that from
the beginning that that's actually all
it was and I think that now it's even
Trump in his sort of coded delusions of
grandeur language effectively
acquiescing to that send me your
thoughts about this also about our
conversation about socialism and social
democracy I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this today's episode is made
possible in part by better help calm
slash Pakman I've spoken about the
unfair and unfortunate stigma that there
can be around therapy there shouldn't be
and better help makes things even easier
for you if you've been thinking about
getting involved and working with a
therapist you get access to fully
licensed experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer all you have to do is go to
better help calm slash Pakman you fill
out a questionnaire they match you with
a counselor that'll work best for you
you can ask if you want that your
therapist not be religious if that is
important to you and at any point if you
think your therapist is not a good fit
you can switch and work with somebody
else it's less expensive than seeing a
counselor in person but better help also
gives you unlimited access to your
counselor you can talk to them every day
if you want you will not get that
with an in-person therapist so go to
better help calm slash Pakman so easy to
sign up and get started we've put a link
in the video description if you're
watching on YouTube check it out better
help calm slash PA que ma N